I should highlight this and I hope
hopefully it's okay that you were
running a little bit late and you sent
me this text which is which people do
really rarely and there's a subtle act
of kindness within that text so the the
you the the text you sent was that
um I just decreased the amount of stress
in your life or something like this by
saying it's cool but that means that you
were you were you're signaling that you
were stressed
because you care enough to be there on
time and that was like that made me feel
really special I was like oh you know
people don't know people don't often
don't always do that because that puts
you also that makes you vulnerable
vulnerable and I actually thought that
after I sent it but I feel that most of
the day right any interaction like uh
God I just exposed myself but absolutely
I was excited to be here and I didn't
want you to think that I didn't care
I think being a therapist has shown me
that it really it's so lucky to be in
that position because you meet people
that you would have thought are cooler
than you or smarter than you or just
somehow impervious to life and you
realize that we are all in it together
we all want to be cared about and liked
we don't want to be liked as a baseline
I some people will say they don't care
but everybody does it's human and I have
gotten much better being a therapist
much more comfortable showing caring
showing love and genuineness and
vulnerability than I think I ever would
have been otherwise and that kind of
vulnerability is what's required to do a
positive interaction in a relationship I
think so and and people have different
levels of comfort right so
um but as long as it's working for both
partners and typically you have to
communicate to figure out what your
partner what makes your partner feel
cared about however you might be working
for instance with an older couple and I
have a couple that's perfectly happy and
they sort of have a system it works for
them if there's some sort of a rupture
if they get in some sort of a
disagreement they don't talk it out she
might go to the store run an errand
doing do a little shopping he'll work in
the wood shop and then they'll come back
and there is a repair attempt though but
it's maybe she'll say hey do you want to
have dinner or come you know I made your
favorite dinner and or he'll say hey I
recorded your favorite show you want to
watch it tonight so they don't need to
process it but there is an understanding
between them that we're still in this
together we care about each other and
there's a repair attempt
most people need to be able to process
it verbally and talk about what happened
not all so for most people if there's a
conflict you should talk about and
resolve it and repair it versus like
just put it behind you I I don't want to
say should I guess it depends on the
couple yeah everybody processes emotions
differently everybody handles emotional
expression differently I mean I have
couples where I have one person in the
partnership who has autism and the other
doesn't and so they're obviously going
to have different ways of communicating
or processing what happened we all have
different perspectives it really depends
on what makes a person feel like it's
been repaired what makes a person feel
understood does that need to be verbal
or in the case of that older couple I
have where they know they understand one
another because there's a gentleness
toward one another after